el ligamento cruzado anterior oa cl por
sus siglas en inglés es uno de los
cuatro ligamentos principales que
conecta el fémur con la tibia el ac l
proporciona estabilidad cuando usted
mueve la rodilla se puede producir un
desgarro del ac l
si la articulación de la rodilla sobre
rota o si usted recibe un golpe directo
en la parte delantera de la rodilla si
él hace l se desgarra por completo el
médico le puede recomendar una cirugía
para repararlo antes del procedimiento
recibirá anestesia raquídea que
adormecer a su cuerpo desde el pecho
hacia la parte inferior o anestesia
general la que lo mantendrá dormido
durante el procedimiento durante el
procedimiento artroscópico el cirujano
hará unas pequeñas incisiones alrededor
de la rodilla a través de las cuales
insertará instrumentos quirúrgicos
incluso una cámara la cámara transmitirá
imágenes a un monitor de tv las que el
cirujano verá durante el procedimiento
primero el cirujano quitará las partes
restantes del desgarro del ac l de su
rodilla
y luego extraer aparte del tendón
rotuliano para utilizar como injerto u
obtener tejido donante
el cirujano creará puntos de unión para
el injerto mediante la perforación de un
pequeño túnel en el extremo de la tibia
y luego otro en el extremo del fémur
el cirujano ubicará un extremo del
injerto del tendón rotuliano en el túnel
tibial
luego levantará el injerto a través de
la articulación de la rodilla y hacia el
túnel femoral para crear un nuevo tendón
hace l por último el cirujano ubicará
pequeños tornillos en los túneles en
cada extremo del nuevo hace el para
mantenerlo en su lugar durante las
próximas 6 a 8 semanas el crecimiento
óseo rellenar a estos túneles y
estabilizar a el injerto
al final del procedimiento el médico
quitará los instrumentos y cerrará las
incisiones este procedimiento
generalmente dura entre dos a dos horas
y media luego del procedimiento usted
pasará a la sala de recuperación durante
dos a tres horas y posteriormente
regresará a su casa probablemente
necesite una rodillera ortopédica y
muletas durante una a cuatro semanas el
tratamiento físico supervisado comenzará
dos o tres días después de la cirugía y
continuará durante seis a diez semanas
después de este tiempo continúe con
tratamiento auto dirigido el tiempo que
sea necesario una cl reconstruido tarda
aproximadamente nueve meses en curarse
completamente debería evitar deportes de
contacto de raqueta y otros deportes que
requieran cambios de dirección rápida
hasta obtener la aprobación de su médico